stray the game that lets you finally
live every gamer's dream of being a
kitty in a cyberpunk world is nearly
upon us so to prepare you for the latest
game from renowned publisher annapurna
interactive and developer blue12 studios
here's everything you need to know about
stray
[Music]
stray puts you into the furry paws of a
cat traveling through a dystopian blade
runner-esque world populated solely by
robots not much is known about the
game's mysterious plot but as the cat
you'll explore the long forgotten cyber
city in order to uncover a strange
mystery and find your way home to your
family on your journey you'll encounter
and interact with the robo-denizens of
this strange world eventually being able
to communicate with them
in terms of gameplay stray like our
feline friends in general defies simple
explanation being a mashup of
platforming exploration and puzzle
solving it's also a cat simulator which
we all know is the main reason you're
gonna play this game first and foremost
though the game comes with a dedicated
button that lets you meow so don't worry
the game has you covered there you can
even do it during cinematics truly
putting you into the mindset of a cat
who doesn't care for such arbitrary
concerns like story and plot
but more importantly while the game does
contain platforming elements most of the
jumping and hopping around is made more
by button prompts rather than player
control as you explore the city the real
focus is on having you explore that city
with the challenge coming from figuring
out where to go rather than how to
navigate it initially the game's levels
start pretty straightforward and linear
but also contain more open-ended larger
segments for your feline form to explore
and uncover where you need to go further
straight contains puzzle elements
forcing you to try to figure out how to
navigate through its world such as
pushing over plants as every cat does or
utilizing pulley systems to access new
areas however these exploration and
navigation segments are not all
lackadaisical at certain points in the
game you'll be put into a chase sequence
forcing you to time exactly when you
need to take a path at the same time you
won't be able to engage in combat so
your only choice will be to escape this
leads to a need to think quickly and
make precise choices in the moment all
this adds pressure to your decisions and
amps up the adrenaline or catnip rush
however all this is done in service of
the game's world as you move throughout
the city you'll encounter more of the
robots inhabiting it eventually you'll
even be able to talk to them once you
get access to a robot companion named
b12 who can translate for you b12 an
adorable flying drone friend will also
help you navigate the city and help you
figure out where to go next you'll even
be able to take on quests and tasks from
the citizens adding in more complexity
to your exploration and you'll want to
explore this world because all of the
robot citizens as well as this cyber
city are extraordinarily pretty and well
animated further the world and your
place in it are shrouded in mystery
leading you to wonder where exactly this
story takes place the far future a
post-apocalypse another universe are all
part of your feline dreams furthermore
you'll have to answer the question
what happened to all the humans who else
is going to give you head scritches just
the way you like them all in all stray
seems to be a unique gaming experience
that draws from a variety of indie and
unique games like it takes to or inside
sadly as is befitting the independent
nature of our feline friend there is no
multiplayer announced for stray on top
of that there is currently no dlc
announced either meaning stray's 7 to 10
hour experience is all that we get for
now
[Music]
stray is currently a playstation console
exclusive meaning that xbox gamers will
sadly not be able to snag a copy
hopefully they're more dog people stray
will be coming to the playstation 4 and
5 via the playstation store however if
you don't own a playstation console you
can still pick it up on windows with it
already available for pre-order on steam
where it currently is one of the most
wish listed games of all time just shows
you that everybody wants to be a cat
because a cat's the only cat who knows
where it's at
stray is releasing on july 19 2022 and
will only be available digitally at full
price it currently retails at 29.99
however if you pre-order the game on
steam before july 19th you'll get a 10
discount making the game only 26.99
if you'd rather have the game for
playstation but don't want to pay the
full 29.99
you're also in luck stray will be
available for members of the extra
deluxe and premium tiers on playstation
plus at launch sadly if you only have
playstation plus essential you won't be
able to access the game for free
playstation plus extra tier is available
for 14.99 a month and the premium tier
is 17.99 a month bill lux is available
in markets outside of the united states
and its pricing varies based on location
and that's everything you need to know
before you can jump into the cyberpunk
world of our feline friend in stray we
recently had the chance to attend a
preview of stray so check out that video
for more information about the utter
cuteness of this game until then though
don't forget to like and subscribe and
make sure to stay out of the catnip
[Music]